Robbie you were an investment banker or
you did something with yes yeah I was
doing my parents dreams I was I did
finance I worked
yeah the banking world and what happened
I blew it I'll tell you what happened up
now I got laid off right around 9/11 and
I already have used up all my vacation
days I knew that I was just a horrible
investment banker I just I hated it when
I knew it wasn't gonna last I don't know
it just wasn't I you know I knew at that
point my life that I had to at least try
something that I cared about and that
began the journey of me kind of like
spending a year going and doing a lot of
crazy stuff and then eventually after a
while I was in LA I was bartending I was
thinking I'll go to law school and I got
asked to do an audition and next thing
you know I was a full-time actor it was
crazy
yeah how do your parents feel about it
now if you don't mind ma'am I think my
parents love it they're about to you
know success is great everyone's every
parent's excited what it's working sure
but yeah when I first did it they were
super scared yeah because they're you
know naturally conservative but yeah now
they're literally acting now themselves
so it's the tables have turned
sure was there a moment when you almost
went back like I know you said you got
laid off I constantly relapse and think
to myself why am I doing this because
acting is a very abusive relationship
you really have to know what it is and
I'm also not one of those people I'm one
of the rare few who don't believe that
to be an actor it's like all you need to
focus on I actually think to be an actor
you have to have other sources of
happiness other sources of fulfillment
and honestly I think even other sources
of work and then you can really give
yourself to acting because what makes
acting really hard is when when it gets
confused with the career because once
you're relying on acting for money all
of a sudden the desperation works its
way into the audition room and that you
know some people never figure out how to
do that it's a very difficult career
path to really pursue and to also do it
in a way where you're actually able to
enjoy the acting and not be completely
reliant on the ends whether you succeed
or not in order to be happy because we
know that even
no I work a ton and even then it's so
often a struggle Lots ups and down so I
have to remember what it is and what it
means to me and for me at this point in
my life I have a wife I have a kid I
have other sources of fulfillment and I
also have other sources of income
because that's the only way that I can
be happy with acting
you